Film Courage: Aaron, is it your
goal to create something every day?
Aaron Fradkin, that's a good question
it I wouldn't say it's my goal to create
something every day but it's definitely my
goal to be working on something maybe that
I've already created every day I think it's
really important to flex that muscle constantly
when I met Victoria [Fratz] my producing partner
and girlfriend it was actually her instagram
bio that said create every damn day
and I remember really liking that
did creating become a daily habit
for you or working on something
become a daily habit for you
after you saw Victoria's instagram
or that was just always in you anyway and you're
like yeah I get that I think it was the latter
I think I've always been I've always wanted to
create constantly and I think having a partner
having someone to do that with definitely
inspires me and like pushes me to actually
follow through in what I promise myself to
do I think it's easy to get lazy sometimes
and having someone right there by your side saying
we have to finish this is a good sort of kick in
the butt to actually do it but it's definitely
inspiring and helpful having someone with you
what are some of the things that stop you from
creating or working on something every day
this week I would say moving I didn't
really do much creating this week
although we did actually release a making of
video for one of our little horror shorts um
sometimes when I'm writing especially if I'm
writing a screenplay I do try to schedule a
block of the day to actually work on writing
if if I'm not feeling particularly inspired
it does help to sort of take a break from
that project and move to something else
but there's never really a time in my life where
I'm completely unable to work or create something
or work on a project I already have going on I
try to do a little bit every day some days are
way more productive than others though is that
your style anyway are you fairly disciplined
I am pretty disciplined I've been called a
robot before not always in in the best way but
yeah I wake up I work out I pretty much have the
same breakfast every morning and then with my with
my cup of coffee I sit at my desk and I just work
and that'll be either writing or editing and if
I'm not here at home then i'll be on set putting
together a movie or a short film with friends
do you find safety in routine I know some
people who are the opposite where they will
go absolutely crazy if they have to do the same
thing but some people I think crave that routine
I think it helps to have some sort of routine
and discipline but I do always find my life and
my my attitude towards things to be somewhat
paradoxical in that it helps to have a routine
but you also have to be willing to break
that routine it's I think I think I can't
even believe I'm quoting bruce lee but I think
he said something about acting or fighting where
you have to kind of learn everything about your
craft and only then can you break the rules
so I think I apply that on some level what
are 10 things an aspiring writer should know
about writing ten things yes number one get a
good cup of coffee sorry that yeah yeah like
could we count that as one so so ten things
that any writer should know about writing
I think I think definitely definitely staying
caffeinated certainly helps I think experience is
is sort of an obvious one I think in film school
I found that a lot of people were making movies
about things that they knew nothing about
and that sort of bothered me I was always
at least in as an undergrad I didn't really
have much life experience and so I was making
movies for better or worse sometimes without as
much substance but it was still my experience
so I think experience is is a big
one I think discipline and routine
being honest with yourself so honesty is a big one
oh why sorry to interrupt but
why that one that's really good
I think honesty is really important to writing
because I didn't really even start to realize
that I was becoming somewhat of a decent writer
until I was really honest with myself not just
honesty in the sense of digging deep in your
heart and telling your story or anything like
that but more so being honest about your work
trying to be objective looking at it and sort
of knowing deep down or at least telling yourself
deep down what you really think of your work your
writing or your creation I sort of found myself
I don't want to say lying to myself but I would
write something and be like this is
the best I can do it's it's good enough
and as more and more time
went on I started to sort of
say to myself no I can actually do better and I
think that that that is that comes with experience
and I think that's part of just being honest
with yourself admitting that you can do better
awesome I think okay so four so caffeinated
oh is that four I thought that was five
oh sorry okay I must have missed one in there okay
man this is a good question sorry I'm not
just like rolling out with the the answers
can I say travel I think travel is important
meeting all sorts of different types of people
that certainly inspires the characters that I
write I guess routine and discipline was one
that I already said but I think it's equally as
important to be open to breaking that routine
to having this sort of spontaneous fire
inside of you that makes you want to do
something you've never done before I spent a
lot of my college years and post grad years
focusing on comedy and only now at 32 am
I actually diving into horror and I find
that I'm actually really enjoying it and it's not
something that I ever imagined wanting to do but
I think being open to changing your trajectory
of things is is a good thing so spontaneity
and what is that eight I believe so seven or eight
yeah yeah I'm drawing a blank on the last two
I think having a good word
processing program certainly helps
i think I think maybe that just contributes
to the structure of things but I feel
I feel a little bit more inspired
if I have just the proper equipment
to write that is a laptop personally I don't I
don't do like pen and paper or anything like that
and final draft or celtx or something like
that that's a way more technical answer
and I think the last thing is arguably the most
important which would just be the passion the
desire to do it I think you're gonna have a lot
of trouble if you are are not enjoying some part
of it I think it's normal to enter into periods
where you are like I hate this I want to move
on to the next thing already I think accepting
that but still reminding yourself of why you
started this to begin with is super important
and if you have that then you can fall back on it
and I think you will be able to finish just about
everything that you start excellent going back to
number eight about having the proper like writing
implements or whatever have you ever tried to do
a script or write a script just using pages
or word and not using like a software program
I have the I think the last time I get I guess I
should say when I was maybe when I was like 10 or
11 I would actually write books and I would start
by grabbing a whole stack of paper and folding
them and then stapling it and then I would draw
pictures and I would actually draw like write my
story in those books so I basically at the end at
age 11 had a self-published single copy of my book
and then since then I I've probably used word
a couple times and I've scribbled ideas in in
notebooks and I even like on my phone right now I
have a notepad of ideas that I can scroll for days
but when I actually sit down to write a screenplay
now it's mainly just final draft excellent okay
great by the way do you have
those books still that you did
I gotta ask my parents I think we left
those in our basement in massachusetts
and I i'll ask if they cleaned it out or if they
kept them I hope they kept them yeah what's your
process for coming up with story concepts
my process for coming up with story concepts
it ranges from sitting down on a couch with
Victoria with the intention of coming up with
an idea or I could be driving to pasadena
or vegas or assuming that the world is open
and I am listening to music and all of a sudden I
just come up with an idea that i'd like to explore
um so it really I it's it's it's not always as
simple as just sitting down and thinking about
an idea more so it just kind of comes when I
am most relaxed do you think you come up with
story concepts more from memory of things that
happen in the past maybe where you grew up or
going to college or does the present moment and
observing the world around you trigger story ideas
so I would say these story ideas come from what
is happening around me currently but when it
comes time to actually fleshing out a character
and sort of trying to write a dynamic relatable
realistic character I have no choice but to
go to my past and go to my memory and sort of
summon up feelings or memories of people that
went through something similar or some variation
of whatever it is I'm writing about so it's
it's definitely a combination of those two
can you talk about your first couple of weeks
starting a screenplay where does it start and
what are those first two weeks like it definitely
starts with that small nugget of excitement
wherever that may take place on the couch with
Victoria or in my car driving listening to music
and I think the ideas that that really stick
that that I'm thinking about for a few days
or even a few weeks are the ones that I actually
decide to move forward with and begin writing
when I begin writing I will make a cup of coffee
sit down at my computer and just start writing
and I don't really I don't really think too
much about what it is that I'm doing I try
to just get as much out as possible knowing
that a good portion of it will suck and then
handing that to someone like that I trust
like Victoria or even my parents or friends
and getting some feedback now not all of that
happens in two weeks I would say the first
two weeks is mainly spent questioning whether
or not it's a good idea thinking about what
why I would want to tell this story thinking about
why this would be important or how I can make it
important on some level or make it personal to
me and once I decide that it is important to me
then i'll just sit down and and
start working it out on on paper
do you have people you give
it to that are harsh critics
i would say Victoria is my harshest critic yeah
my parents have been pretty pretty supportive
about everything so I take what
they say with a grain of salt
we have a couple of writer friends that we like
sending it to and they give decent feedback
but yeah I definitely prefer to give
it to people that are going to say
I don't want to say meaner things but just more
truthful things sure it's like some people don't
have a filter and that's can be helpful sometimes
and maybe sometimes it's not so helpful but
certainly certainly yeah have you ever had an
idea that you thought was great and you began
writing it and you said what this is just I'm not
into it I've lost interest and then you've resumed
like a year later and you loved it absolutely
there's there's actually two ideas that I can
think of one is a script I wrote a couple years
ago fully with the intention of actually making
just with friends basically just about a guy who
doesn't really have much life experience and so
he sets out to give himself life experience mainly
a traumatic experience and I was really excited by
that idea but then I wrote it and it just didn't
really it didn't really hit the way that I wanted
and so I shelved it and a couple years later
I actually picked it up again read through I
was like there's actually some really good pieces
here and I sort of just over like a few days just
sort of started to edit from page one another one
is it's called the philosophy circle and it's it's
a movie that I actually wrote probably when I was
like 23. and I've that's the only script I can say
that I've actually edited consistently from age
23 to as recently as maybe two years ago so it's
been sort of a work in progress for about seven
years or so and why take so long with something
I think some stories are are more complicated than
others and I think sometimes if you get really
excited about something and that there's something
there but it didn't really strike a chord with you
maybe it's best that you shelve it for a little
bit and then come back later I think that can
benefit a lot of projects whereas some projects
are way more straightforward and regimented
and you either kind of know if you're on the right
track or not within a much smaller period of time
I've heard some writers say I think
it was the writer of the goldfinch
the movie goldfinch that she loves the slow
process of writing and she doesn't want to rush it
I think it took her 12 years or so to finish
that so some people they really savor that that
long process they don't want to rush it
I think that benefits some people and
some projects and I've found myself sort of
going both ways in that regard I've spent a lot
of time on certain projects and then I've sort of
I don't want to say rushed through but definitely
cruised right through I think I the first script
I ever wrote was in a week and I kind of followed
the very traditional three-act structure I knew
exactly where it was going I wouldn't say it was
it was award-winning by the end but some some
stories also just come out of you way easier
than others some some definitely take more time
to marinate and sort of figure out along the way
let's say you've written a screenplay and you
feel that it's a 9 out of 10. it's almost there
how would you get it to be a 10 I don't think you
ever can at least not in your eyes I've never done
anything that I've said this is a 10 out of
10. there's always things that I see room for
improvement is that a bad answer no no that's
good and I think some people are hardwired that
way like nothing is ever they've got to always
tweak things and I think that makes people great
at whatever they do I think you were talking about
that lately you have to be somewhat ocd I think
but yeah I mean I don't even think I've ever done
anything that's nine out of ten I think I think
it's this one giant journey to sort of make that
10 out of 10 project and I think that's what gives
me hope is this constant evolution of wanting to
be better and wanting to make your next project
even more perfect than the last
one but every time I make one I do
look at it and I say to myself that is
significantly better than the last one
at least more often than not so I see growth
and that's that's really all I can ask for
I've never actually finished something and been
like 10 out of 10. have you seen other people's
work that you're like 9 out of 10 10 out of 10.
I've seen other people's work that makes me want
to quit the film industry because I don't think
i'll ever live up to it I mean I remember seeing
inception in theaters and just walking out of the
theater and turning to my friend and saying like
I don't even know if I want to like live in la
anymore and make movies because I'm never going to
make something like that it it is just that that
to me is just such a wonderful brilliant movie um
so so yes I martin mcdonough is another of my
favorites with like screenwriting-wise I just
the dialogue that he writes I aspire to write like
that or or just think on that level but there's
certainly a lot of people that I look up to that
I think I don't know if I can ever be that good
so does that make you then want to stop or
make you want to rise to their level I know
that sounds so cliche sorry I mean I
say that sort of facetiously I will
i'll never stop but but yeah it was sort
of like a funny funny sarcastic joke and
I said that in the movie theater walking out
of inception i'll never want to stop but it's
it's this sort of abstract goal to sort of
make something that you watch and elicit
the same response in yourself that you had
when you watched something like inception
and I don't know if that will ever happen I think
I'm always going to be my harshest critic but it's
definitely something I aspire to do and it's what
keeps me going is just that sort of nugget of hope
well a lot of times something that inspires people
is seeing bad work or even in entrepreneurs they
see some idea and they go I could do better than
that and why does that person get to do that I
want to do it and there you go and there's there's
the trajectory of their career because it was all
built on seeing somebody else do something that
they think they failed at I think that I think
that's human to to look at someone else's work
and and say oh I'm i'm better than that or or I
can I can do that why aren't I why haven't I made
it big yet I sort of and I do that on some level
more so from a business perspective because I
want to be able to make movies and have have a
career and actually support myself doing that so I
asked myself well why are they getting paid all of
this money to do something I know I have the skill
set to do so I don't really I don't really think
in that way creatively as much because the story
that you choose to tell the movie that you make is
oftentimes a personal choice and and who's to
say one is better than the other I think what
you can judge is sort of the the the technicals
of it the maybe the business of it why is their
movie picked up by lionsgate and distributed
worldwide when mine had all the same shot on the
same camera and has just as much character growth
and three-act structure format and all of that
do you think it's good to have a little
bit of a a chip on the shoulder in terms of
having a competitor or or does that not fuel
you I think some people it really fuels them
I think and others it doesn't I know I know
it fuels some people I know Victoria has said
that it certainly helps to have have that I don't
want to say chip on your shoulder but that kind of
a little bit of ego like like as though it's a
competition I honestly I've never felt any kind
of competition I very much felt like I've sort
of been on my own journey sort of growing and
like I said before I am my harshest critic so
something really isn't good enough until I say
it's good enough and it certainly helps going to
film festivals and having people pat you on the
back and say that was a wonderful movie like great
job and it gives me a little bit more confidence
but even if they said that was a terrible movie I
would probably still move along and make another
project regardless but it it certainly helps
is there such a thing as story intuition I
would lean to saying yes I think I think certain
people do have something innate within them that
that where they just understand character and and
they understand the direction that stories need
to go in I think other people might require
a little bit more work to get there so I'm
not saying that some people just have it and some
people don't I just think some people maybe have
a little bit more of an advantage based on where
they're from or where their mind was focused at
on at a young age that seems like a very
scientific answer to a metaphysical question
where do you think you fall on that spectrum I
wouldn't say I have all the intuition in the world
but I do I I've been interested in storytelling
and filmmaking since I was 11 or 12 so
I every the way that I've perceived the world has
sort of been with that in mind I want to make a
movie so I think that certainly helps when early
on in your life that you want to do something in
entertainment because you think in that way
and so your brain becomes wired in that way
and I think it helps when fast forward
15 years you decide to write a screenplay
you have now spent all this time watching movies
thinking I want to do that and so it sort of it
helps whereas there are a lot of people that might
be a mechanical engineer and then when they're
30 years old they're like actually I want
to become a screenwriter and then it takes
a little bit of learning and a little bit of
education to to get there and they might be even
better than I was but it requires more I guess
proactiveness it requires a little bit more
education to get there right so on one end of
the spectrum maybe a story technician and on
the far end a story alchemist or something yeah
that's a good way of putting it in the middle is
is sort of both okay that sounds good do you
think that if intuitively someone doesn't know
a story that they'll never be a writer you
talked about the engineer this hypothetical
writer I think I actually believe that anyone
can be a writer I think I think it's all just a
matter of how much you're willing to put into
it to actually tell an interesting story or
complete your story I think everyone has a life
experience that can be interesting in some way
and I think it's just sort of up to them to have
the will to learn how to take that experience and
translate it into a story that anyone can watch
and anyone can understand and anyone can enjoy
and does the life experience
have to be necessarily traumatic
definitely not no it doesn't have to be
traumatic it just has to be it just has to be
interesting and memorable to you and and I think
some of those stories will resonate with
a lot of people some of those stories will
resonate with a small group of people but
I find it hard to believe that there is
anyone in this world who has only experienced one
thing that no one else has ever experienced before
and even if that is the case then that
would be a pretty damn interesting story
so writers can be happy productive people they
don't have to be absolutely self-loathing no
they definitely don't have to be no
I think it's normal to go through
periods of self-loathing and self-loving but
yeah it's I don't think it's one or the other
what do you think about learning everything you
can about structure and then forgetting it kind
of going back to the bruce lee quote right I think
I think it's a great idea to take that approach
I think it's very important to have a foundation
an educational foundation on whatever craft you're
doing because there are plenty of people that
came before you that knew what they were doing
and they did it exceptionally well and so you want
to learn from those people and once you learn sort
of how to put together a story or put together a
movie this really can be this can be attributed
to any craft in the world then you can then infuse
your own experience onto that and create something
new and original how do you develop character
by looking at my own experience or talking to
other people that have had an experience similar
to whatever character it is that I'm writing I
like to think I have some level of intuition with
how people behave but I'm always surprised and
especially when writing a female character for
example I'm not the best source of information
because I'm not a female so I will ask girls
i'll go to Victoria and ask like help me help
me craft this character because everybody thinks
in a in a different way and it's it's definitely
important to have that sort of well-rounded point
of view and it's it's important to sort of have
I think multiple voices be just as there would be
multiple characters in your story it's important
to have multiple voices at least giving you
the writer feedback giving you the writer some
direction to go in or some understanding of these
characters what would you say is the most perfect
fictional character whether be in a novel or film
one of my f this is a strange answer to that one
of my favorite characters in film and one of my
favorite movies is a serious man coen brothers
and the main the main character in that
is basically going about his everyday life
just trying his hardest trying his best trying
to be a good person and there's there's always
something around him that's happening that's
sort of throwing a wrench into his plan
and it's not like he did anything wrong he's just
an ordinary guy with a family and one thing after
another happens and a storm is literally coming
throughout the entire duration of the movie
and I thought that that was just such a beautiful
representation of life and when I watched that
movie and every time I've watched it thereafter
I've watched it multiple times and find new little
gems within it I it's just really resonated with
me I've i've looked at that movie and watched that
character a million times and thought yes I can
relate to that I love that movie as well I love
the character of psy yeah and not so much because
psy I mean sai is actually a horrible person but
you don't know spoiler alert but you don't know
that at first and so the fact that he seems a
little more genuine and then the the needle moves
and you see wow this person's actually like a
saboteur and I don't know such as life you don't
always you don't always know sometimes exactly
yeah but that's that's a great film as well
and it's a it's a great character study and I
also like the brother in the film I thought
the brother was a good because his life is
probably more damaged than michael stalwark's
character exactly it's richard kind right
oh is that right okay sorry yeah I don't know
that's the that's the actor's name I think
yeah okay why did you switch from comedy
filmmaking to horror well I wouldn't say that
I switched as much as I'm just sort of trying
something new at this time I like like I said
before I definitely needed a career and ever since
I was in high school I've always known that horror
is a great way to break in but my instincts were
sort of more pushed towards comedy and so I spent
a lot of time doing that and I think I did it
decently well but now in in sort of an effort to
to experiment and also launch a career
I think it was a great it was a great
it was just a great what
what word am I looking for
idea to just sort of try a different genre because
I could sort of flex my filmmaking muscle which
which I wasn't really doing in comedy as much
but with horror I think there's a lot more room
to sort of explore and be creative and inventive
and work with lighting and camera angles and then
just from a career perspective when we release
these I mean these get a lot more attention than
if I were to release a comedy sketch or a even a
romantic comedy movie people people really love
horror you think too because horror can be
more not just regional but other people in
other countries can pick up more on scares
rather than a little nuance here and there
absolutely funny thing that's that's
a huge part of it I think I think
someone in japan who doesn't speak any english
can still see a scary monster and have a feeling
whereas they might not watch king of staten
island and understand the nuances of every
joke sure sure and there's east coast humor
versus west coast too so that's your true
the east coast yeah that's true there's definitely
there's definitely differences there what if you
learned about making people laugh I've always
liked making people laugh because it's it's it's a
visceral response that sort of gives you
as a creator some sometimes the validation
that you need that you're putting out
some good content or good material
it seeing I mean seeing a smile on someone's face
makes me smile so it's there there's no harm there
there's there's a lot of good
stuff about making people laugh
do you think sarcasm is is a dirty word
no I'm incredibly sarcastic and I don't I
don't mean that sarcastically I'm dead serious
what have you learned about writing something
scary I think I've heard a lot of people say this
I do find a lot of similarities between horror
and comedy you kind of have a build up and then a
punch line or a set up in a punch line or a a slow
build and then a scare so they're very similar and
so if there's one thing I've learned about horror
is that it's actually very similar to comedy
and you kind of get that same visceral reaction
from your audience seeing them jump as you would
in comedy seeing them laugh and it and it
feels good to see that it's it's super cool
and and we we've been releasing these
horror shorts on our on our youtube channel
and I've seen so many people make reaction videos
to watching our horror shorts and that is a very
rewarding and interesting thing to see literally
just looking into someone's eyes watching them as
they watch your movie I've never ever experienced
that in anything else I've ever made before but
it's it's super cool which horror protagonist do
you most identify with that's a tough question I
it seems like a lot of protagonists in horror
movies have experienced or gone through some
really traumatic life experience so I'm sure I
identify on some level obviously they're they're
complete they're exaggerated tenfold in movies I
just saw doctors sleep and I loved that one ewan
mcgregor's character was fantastic i'd have to
think about that one a little bit more it's it's
hard to imagine a a protagonist in a horror film
that that I've really resonated with before maybe
the babadook the the lead and the babadook that
was a really interesting movie because I think
everyone has some demon inside
of them in some way or another
and I think that's what made that movie so
great is it was just a visual representation
of something we all we all experience on
some level maybe not grief to that extent
some people probably have definitely
have experienced grief to that extent
a lot of people even if they haven't can still
understand this sort of demon inside that
is wants to get out and and it's it's that movie
was just such an interesting exploration of that
and sort of how you either censor yourself or push
certain things away and yeah it was a great movie
can you talk more about your process for writing
comedy comedy it's it's it's very very hard
to write and I wouldn't say I have any particular
process I think when writing a screenplay
it's really important and and this is definitely
true for just about any genre but I think in
comedy in particular it's very important
that the concept itself starts off from a
in a funny interesting place and I think it I
think for me I know Victoria hates this word
but but when something is grounded even if
it's sort of an a crazy abstract supernatural
movie or concept so long as the characters and
the reactions stay grounded I think that's very
important to comedy so you want to start with
a concept that is inherently funny and then you
sort of build characters off of that that support
the concept and are completely different and I
definitely enjoy writing the dialogue I think more
so than anything else because just writing odd
weird quirky fast-paced funny jokes is rewarding
and if it it's fun to write because I sometimes
find myself laughing while coming up with ideas
whereas if I'm if I'm writing a a drama or a
horror movie I it's not always as fun sometimes
it's just scary or you kind of have to go
dig a little deeper to actually find something
worth writing about comedy it just if it makes
you laugh I think it it works so it's definitely
more fun did you watch a lot of seinfeld when you
were a kid absolutely and curb your enthusiasm
curb your enthusiasm got me through high school
and college and it still does today and a lot
of people even say I'm a lot like larry david
do comedy and horror have the same story beats I
think they're very similar for sure like I said
before I do think that har will sort of
have a slow build and then a jump scare
whereas comedy will have a setup and a punch line
when it comes to the actual overall structure
of of a full-length screenplay I think just about
every genre should follow generally the same kind
of rules loose rules can be broken but in that
regard I don't think there's any difference
did you ever try your hand at stand-up
comedy aaron my mom did I haven't
I've actually I do have a word document with
some like stand-up jokes or I have it in my phone
somewhere but I've never tried stand-up I don't
I don't know if that's something I want to do
how cool so would your mom perform at comedy
clubs I think she's tried it just a couple times
yeah I think the first time
she did it she was in her 50s
wow yeah and so do you remember like I guess
you're probably too young to go to the club or
can you tell me about that that's
fascinating well I actually I wasn't there
I was I was out here in l.a but she just there was
this it was like a cafe in massachusetts and they
had an open mic night and she went and tried it
out and I was thinking good for you that's that's
awesome I don't I don't know if I would have the
confidence to do that I do think stand-up comedy
is one of the most difficult performances
any any human can can do I think it's it's
nerve-wracking it's difficult and if I were to do
stand-up i'd want to be i'd want to be everything
intellectually stimulating hilarious low
brow and highbrow all at the same time
and it it would require just as much work if not
more as writing a screenplay which is something
i'd prefer to spend my time doing anyway so just
with story beats there's probably timing and
things like that with stand up as as well oh
absolutely I think some of the best stand-up
comedians actually have a full structured
story well they'll start with something
and sort of have the story that weaves in and out
all the way through up until the end which is just
one giant callback joke to everything that came
before it and I have a lot of respect for that and
I love stand up every time I see a new stand-up
special released on netflix I get very excited
yeah and and not just the concept of hecklers
but also people in the audience like if
you watch old robin williams footage people
aren't even like challenging him and he's just
pointing them out and so he has new material
to work off of even if his set is or was
one thing he's got new things to kind of work off
and pull absolutely I mean robin williams is he's
genius I think I've seen some of those some of
those videos that you're talking about I mean
yeah he's he's super quick and you definitely need
a thick skin to to do that and you just need to
really be able to think on your feet which I can't
which or at least not as well as evidenced by this
interview I'm not coming up with the answers right
away I definitely am the type of person that I
need time to like think about things and give a
good answer I don't want to just come out with it
and so I don't know how i'd respond to
hecklers I wouldn't necessarily have a
quip just that that quick so again going back to
the the competitor or the the chip on the shoulder
you'd rather be the the michael jordan documentary
he showed that he needed that right right push him
and make him great so you're more the one
that's the internal again going back to
the two schools yeah for better or worse I
don't know which which outlook is better but
yeah I I at least try not to
have a chip on my shoulder
some chips work some chips definitely do
I mean that you need you need a certain
level of confidence in yourself to just push
through but yeah I think I think it's like I
said before I'm sort of I'm sort of a paradox
I think a lot of people are a paradox you need
your days where you're like I'm king of the world
I can do anything and then you need the days
just as much where you question everything your
reality who am I and why am I doing this with my
life I think that balance is important and I think
it's dangerous to tip anything in any one extreme
direction but it's a giant pendulum that you just
need to constantly balance so your mom only did
two stand up I love that segue okay yeah she I
think she tried it I think she tried it twice and
yeah she said she got a few laughs at my father's
expense but I think I think it went pretty well
for her first time what have you learned about
writing villains writing villains I think
writing villains should be approached the
same way that writing any other character or
protagonist should be approached I a good villain
is you understand why they're doing what they're
doing and you understand what they want just as
much as you understand what the protagonist wants
that's who's one of your favorite villains one
that actually comes to mind is javier bardem
and no country for old men there's something
terrifying about him but in the end he just
kind of dies naturally without any with kind of
indirectly of the events of the movie that took
place see it kind of which is what also what
I love about that movie is you have this
these tropes that that the characters
and the story follows and then it's just
completely broken by the end and you're sort
of left with an even more terrifying feeling
or a more freeing feeling depending on how
you want to look at it that there really is
no distinct good or bad in the world and
if there is there is no real justice or
maybe there is it's so it's all a paradox
it's all a matter of how you look at it
so that's I think that that was he was a
great character and that was a great movie
what about what's one of your most hated
villains I feel like if I actually watched
a movie and genuinely hated a character I
might I might not like the movie that much
a part of me wants to kind of like on some
level everybody that I watch even if they're
the antagonist you kind of want to like
who they are and what they're about
or at least get something out of it someone
that is just pure evil I find to be unrealistic
so now I'm trying to think of movies
with sort of just purely evil characters
and I guess I would need I would still need some
more time time with that man I don't I don't know
what about the joker I do I do think that the
joker they they definitely did a good job of
and I'm talking about like the most recent
joker they definitely did a good job
of sort of showing this guy who is
disturbed I personally had trouble
relating to to that character at least in the
latest version mainly just because it was a
movie about this mentally ill person and and it's
it's it can be fascinating to watch at certain
points but he wasn't really as much of a villain
in that movie I maybe in like the classic batman
uh comics he the joker is certainly portrayed more
so as a villain and in that case it is more black
and white but the the origin of him I guess is is
definitely more of a character study on someone
with mental illness and therefore I wouldn't
even look at it look at him as a villain at all
I don't know if that's a pretentious answer but
yeah no no there's been a lot of debate I know
about that character and yeah yeah I mean that
was an interesting movie and and I wouldn't say
it was my favorite movie I didn't hate it I didn't
love it I it was definitely a different approach
but yeah I look at the dark knight and I find
I find heath ledger in that movie just to be
very well rounded and a wonderful wonderfully
written villain because he is actually
he's giving reason for why what he for what he
does and the the sort of again what's the what's
the word I'm looking for the the predicaments
that he puts the protagonist in are very difficult
situations that it's like what do you do in this
situation it's it's a and I think that's that's
a great predicament to put your protagonist in
is something that anyone can watch and be like
I don't know what I would do in that situation
I want to see how this person is going to do it
so you love christopher nolan I do yeah yeah I
believe you made your first feature film in 2013
did you think upon making that your life was
going to change I guess if I were to ever have
a period of my life where I did have a chip on
my shoulder it was in 2012 making that movie um
i I didn't really I didn't know
what was gonna happen with it
I was very much focused on just making a movie
that I wanted to make and had zero intention of
trying to make something marketable or
or anything all I wanted out of it was
sort of just I just wanted to open a door and have
maybe an agent that can help me make my next movie
or garner the attention of some investors
that would finance the next movie
while making it it was an absolute blast and
I definitely hope for the best I didn't if you
were to actually ask me truthfully if I thought
this was gonna be my big break i'd probably say
no I don't think so but I just sort of wanted to
prove to myself that I could make a coherent story
and and I think I successfully did that
at least when I was 20 23 years old or so
do you really think that's a chip on your shoulder
or more just creative longing just wanting to make
something it was probably probably more creative
longing I mean I it wasn't like in a cocky way I
of course hoped that we would get in a sundance
and make a million dollars and there was a small
part of my mind that thought that could happen I
could see that happening now I don't really think
in that way so so when I was younger I definitely
the whole sundance dream and selling your movie
for for millions and millions of dollars was
it was much more of a possibility in my mind
back then whereas now it might happen but I don't
even I don't even think about that now now I focus
so much more on the actual content I'm trying to
make and just making the best possible movie I can
would you advise other first-time
filmmakers not just a short but a feature
that it'd be really more of a again cliche term
but a passion project rather than aiming for this
incredible distribution deal
that's that's a very difficult question to answer
and I know I'm sure a lot of people will watch
this and and I want to I want to be careful with
my word choice because I don't want to like lead
anyone down the wrong path obviously everyone's
different and personally I think it's important to
think about the business of it and also think
creatively just how everything else seems to
be a balance in life you also need the balance
of business and creative like you at least if
if you want to make a living doing this and
only this personally I think that's really
important there are plenty of people who I who I
look up to that not once have ever thought about
the business part of things in fact they despise
it and they've only focused on the creative part
of it and and that's worked out well for them and
then there's plenty of people that only focus on
the business and you watch their movie and you
can tell but the business is really working out
and the the creativity part of it kind of suffers
for me I like to keep both in mind all the time
when I'm actually on set or when I'm
actually in front of my computer writing
I first and foremost I do my best to
compartmentalize and I just focus on the story and
what it is that I'm actually writing about what it
is I want to say and then when we go through the
revision stage it's like all right well this might
be more relatable or we might be able to actually
call this a horror film if we
add a few more jump scares or
just sort of add to it fluff it up to sort of take
your original creative vision and make it a little
bit more marketable so you can make money and do
it again what mistakes did you make with 15 north
that have always stuck with you that then going
forward with the new project you always remember
those mistakes and try to correct anything whether
it's in pre-production post I think I spent too
much on post-production I think I think I realized
later on that I could actually do a lot more
myself at least in in that small of a budget I
could do a lot more instead of spending money
and hiring someone else to do certain things
although then again the entire landscape has
changed and you're able to do so much more from
home now than you were just seven years ago
i'm trying to think of of the biggest mistake I
would say the biggest mistake that I made on my
first movie was not spending enough time on the
script I definitely approached the entire project
with this attitude of I just want to make a
movie I want to make it real I'm just going
to keep the cameras rolling and get natural
performances it's very sort of mumble core
style and I think that that is good but I
didn't prepare enough I feel like I could have
fleshed out the story a lot more with just really
focus on a more traditional three-act structure
and and focus on writing characters with more
depth and and that sort of thing if there was one
thing I could do over again that would probably be
it is just spend more time focusing on the actual
script do you think that prompted your youtube
channel because you give such helpful tips with
your channel do you think that prompted you to
want to start it or no certainly I mean I think
the the content I'm putting out on on
my youtube channels is basically just
everything I wanted to see when I was when
I was a few years younger I wanted to see
people creating content from home by
themselves and I enjoy that I love seeing
people and what they're able to do without big
studios behind them would I take a studio job
of course but I really get a kick out of this
just home brewed do-it-yourself kind of approach
i think your top video is about the
using the drawing aspect in adobe oh yeah
the the scribble animation that's funny did
that would be so popular no not not really
I mean I know it's a it's a popular effect but
yeah with that kind of thing you never really
know it's gonna be popular with our other
channel social house films that's a lot more
cut and dry if you if you make a short horror film
and it looks pretty and the monster looks scary
then it's probably going to do pretty well
these tutorials it's it's hard to sort
of be on the pulse of what effect
is going to be the most desirable
now that now that tick tock is a thing a lot
of people are trying to like create their
own effects at home and and so I never
know what that next thing is going to be
I have a quote here aaron and it reads I
selfishly like a lot of first-time directors
because they over prepare they are super eager
and they have very little ego and that quote
is from none other than mark duplass of the
duploss brothers I definitely agree with that
yeah I think I do think that when you're a new
director you feel like you have something to prove
and I think it was david f sandberg who said
that you want to prepare 200 just to get 100
results and I think especially first-time
directors because they have something to prove or
they're nervous they tend to over prepare a
little bit and when it comes to filmmaking that's
definitely not a bad thing I I've noticed that my
movies get significantly better if I actually plan
every single shot every single moment it sounds
grueling and tedious and difficult and it
absolutely is but it also it also sounds obvious
of course you prepare you do a better job but it
makes a world of a difference I remember earlier
on in my in my career I remember you you actually
asked if what was one of the biggest mistakes I
learned with my first feature and I would say not
preparing every single shot I think especially
on a much smaller budget film if you actually
over prepare exactly what you're going to
shoot and you're going to know every single
moment that it is that you're shooting then the
the finished product is gonna be so much better
did you storyboard do anything like that I did
not storyboard 15 north it was it was very much
again from this approach of I just want to
get two cameras rolling at the same time
sort of shoot it in this very
mumble corey documentary style
didn't want to really do that much planning I did
have a loose shot list just to sort of make sure
I covered basically got all the coverage that I
needed but since that movie I've definitely spent
a lot more time focusing on what's actually in the
frame on that movie it was just sort of like let's
point a camera at this actor get their lines and
let's just do a couple takes of that and move on
I don't really do that anymore how does
a writer or filmmaker earn their audience
that's that's also a good question I think a
writer filmmaker probably earns their audience
by being honest with themselves
I think it's like making a friend
if you are if you're a good person and you have
good intentions and you care about what it is
that you're saying I think people are going
to listen and they're going to be interested
if you if you seem like you're making a movie or
telling a story for all the wrong reasons I think
that's gonna it's gonna shine through in your work
so I think you you definitely earn an audience's
trust in that way and then of course the the
technical aspect of it if it looks terrible it's
going to be distracting and nobody nobody's going
to really even take the time to watch it even if
the content itself is riveting and good you kind
of you sort of need this baseline production value
to say okay I know what I'm doing now hear what
I have to say and what if you build an audience
and they become so invested in your stories and
your characters that they revolt because they
wanted those characters and stories to
become something else but you as the creator
it's your imagination but how much does the
audience say involved in some of that how much
say do they have if I could start a revolution
i'd I i'd be happy I could I could die early um
i I guess the best example I mean I've never
really made anything overly controversial
that would cause anyone to revolt about anything
however there is one horror short that we just
released a few weeks ago called diet and we
wanted to play with the tropes of sort of what
makes a traditional horror film where you just
have this usually it's a girl just home alone
and something scary happens she hears a noise or
something is at the window and she goes up to it
and it's nothing and then she goes into bed and
then turns around there's a scary monster and
that's it that's the end it's it's like the most
cliche kind of like little horror short you can
imagine and so I was thinking of a way to play
around with that and have all of those same tropes
but then at the very end you just have that main
character die of natural causes in which case
he just dies of choking on a carrot and
then a monster in the closet reveals herself
and sighs with disappointment because she couldn't
fulfill her duty as a scary monster who terrorizes
her victims so we released that and I thought it
was like kind of a funny comedy horror idea a lot
of people were confused by it a lot of people got
it a lot of people were like what the hell did I
just watch that that doesn't make any sense
so that was actually very interesting and it
was particularly interesting to watch reaction
videos of that film Aaron are you saying that
every horror short that you do people do reaction
videos too just about every horror short act
actually I think every horror short that we've
made there are reaction videos online and and
I do love watching them some we even have shared
a couple to our social house films facebook page
do they usually let or do you find them
in search there's only been one person
that's ever let us know everyone else
just they just do it on their own but
I mean that's that's fair I they they don't need
to let us know if they want to watch it and react
to it then so be it that's why it's there how does
that feel that people are that affected by your
work that they're taking time to make a reaction
video I think it's super cool it's the it's the
it's just such a cool feeling and experience to
watch someone else watch what you just made and
literally look them in the eye every moment of
the film that you that you just put out there
and sometimes you see genuine
terror on their face and it's
it's just such a rewarding thing to see that kind
of visceral response from a complete stranger
have you ever reached out to a creator and
given feedback good or bad I tried to get
an internship at apatow productions when I
first moved out here actually I made a short
horror film come to think of it
it was a short hard documentary
it was like a mockumentary about the
making of a zombie movie about love
and one of the guys that I made it with was family
friends with larry david and gave him a copy
and I think I was like I don't know I was maybe 17
or 18 at this time and larry david watched it and
told my friend hey tell jesse and aaron the other
filmmakers that they did a great job and that was
that was super cool so I remember kind of pushing
my friend like hey you should larry david you
should give this to him not necessarily his genre
but i'd be curious to I'm a huge fan of larry
david so i'd love to see what he thinks how do you
work with actors I actually read a book on this
it's called i'll be in my trailer I forget who
wrote it very well known director and there
was a lot a lot of very interesting sort
of experiences that this director had and
i think I subconsciously remembered
a lot of that book too which is
you kind of you want to create an environment that
is comfortable much like you guys are doing right
now it helps me if I feel comfortable when I'm
talking or performing or whatever so you want to
you want to keep things comfortable does to me it
doesn't really matter what the feel of the scene
is everyone should always be as comfortable
as you can make them all the time I think
and once you've sort of created that environment
then you want them to know that they're open to
experimentation that they're open to sort
of try things that they might otherwise
be scared to do if they feel like this
is a visionary director and they know
that director knows exactly what he or she wants
to do then I think it's important to give that
actor the freedom to experiment try new things
because I don't always know best and sometimes
actors have done something that I've I could not
have imagined of and that's super cool to watch
whereas if we go back to stand-up comedy
even though people have the freedom to be
spontaneous in the room that feeling isn't
always going to be there you think you think
one brings out a better performance in people
i think I think I mean I
definitely think stand-up comedy is
is definitely it's it's a
form of acting for sure um
it's I also think stand-up comedy is probably
one of the most uncomfortable positions you can
put yourself in but I think I think good stand-ups
it's sort of on them because there is no director
it's a completely different medium it's on them to
make themselves feel comfortable on stage and and
feel give themselves the freedom to do what they
want if that makes sense sure sure you're right
yeah because each one kind of has its own role
there's some very self-deprecating comics there's
some that they turn it on the audience yeah so
that's very true it is it is their character
do you still make money or residuals
off your first feature film
I think I made a total of about 25 now off of 15
north I guess that was a good learning experience
the biggest mistake with 15 north actually
come to think of it came to distribution
not with the actual creation of the movie but
with the getting it out there into the world we
went through like a third party sort of tertiary
company that approached us after our premiere and
they said that they wanted to distribute the movie
they loved it we were young early 20s we were
super excited to even have a distribution company
approach us so we signed the contract didn't get a
lawyer basically just signed it away and this was
a like I said it was a third party company that
basically just went through an aggregator and we
never saw a dime back we never saw anything and so
what I learned from that movie was really
know what you're doing when it comes to
distribution and get a lawyer if you can and
do your research and be open to a negotiation
you're allowed to this is a business and you
are allowed to negotiate ownership for your film
do you still own the rights to it so about two
years ago I had the contract terminated that
tertiary company actually went out of business
and or was bought by another company and so we
terminated the contract and now I self-distributed
it on amazon amazon prime yeah which is why I say
I made about 25 bucks because I think I get
six cents for every hour watched or something
like that yeah so how long was it sort of out of
your hands you said it was 2012 when you started
filming it was 2012 when we shot it I think it
came out in 2013 and then the contract I think
ran for six years or seven years and I terminated
it maybe just a couple months before the contract
was expired anyway your second feature film
electric love is on hulu currently yes it is
and so how did that happen how did you how did
you get that hulu deal well I took everything I
learned from my first movie 15 north and and when
especially when it came to distribution and we
applied it to electric love we had we had a friend
who knew someone at gravitas ventures and he was
able to connect us with the with the people over
there and they were interested in the film we even
were offered a an mg minimum guarantee or like
an advance which was for like about a tenth of
our budget which was super exciting because I had
never i'd never experienced anything like that and
distribution for independent film is such a
mystery to me so we we actually did not jump right
away we were sort of determining whether or not we
wanted to go with that or perhaps field inquiries
from sales agents or other distribution companies
but anyway we ended up going with gravitas and
they had it distributed internationally
and then they sold it to hulu and that
was it was very exciting and we actually made
about half of our budget back just from that
so it was a very validating and exciting
and just super cool thing to happen
and what types of things do you need to do to
get the film ready to show on a platform like
hulu actually I'm trying to think of we actually
just got an email today with a list of things that
apparently they're still missing so you need to
deliver the film in its 4k format you need to put
together an m e track which is a music and effects
track which is basically without the dialogue
that way internationally they can dub over it in
any language you need a complete transcription
of every line spoken in the entire movie there's
there's a lot of deliverables that are required
and every platform sort of requires something
different but the distributor sort of tells you
hey we need this or hey we need this and then we
just rushed to do it and if I can do it myself
then I will I think there were a couple things
that we needed to hire out like the the m e track
but but the distributor tells you what they
need and so you give it to them how long
has it been on hulu I think it's been on hulu
now for I want to say a year I it actually no
maybe six months Victoria would know I forget
I forget has anyone reached out to you about the
film I loved it watched it this reminds me of me
I've got I've gotten a couple like friend
request friend requests on facebook or dms
and on instagram and but not nothing crazy I think
more so the the actors have received some feedback
I've heard zach one of the stars of the movie say
he's has people from around the world message him
yeah I did post a copy or a photo
of me holding up the blu-ray
when it came out on reddit and I posted that to
the filmmakers subreddit and I think I got like
a thousand up votes or something a lot of other
filmmakers were asking questions about it and
I do definitely try to make myself available to
people independent filmmakers that have questions
about distribution I think it's such a secret for
some reason and nobody likes discussing numbers
and I think that only works to
the advantage of the distributor
and I think it's important for filmmakers
like us to actually share this information and
learn how to properly distribute your movie and
make money on it if you can what have you found
is the best way to make money as a filmmaker to
shoot weddings probably no I mean it it depends
what what level you're at and in high school that
that is what I did I shot weddings at bar mitzvahs
nowadays I probably make the most getting
hired by companies to just shoot music videos
we we actually just started monetizing our
youtube channel so that's that's a nice
extra source of income and surprisingly making
independent films that fit within a certain budget
now just with the with all of these streaming
platforms it's actually a lot easier to make your
money back and then some on independent movies so
electric love was about a hundred thousand dollars
and so far I think we've made about 70 000 of
that back and it's a seven year term that you
sign with the distributor that we signed and so
over seven years we certainly plan on breaking
even hopefully and then even making a little bit
after that it doesn't happen immediately so you
definitely have to give it some time before you
even see your first check in the mail I think
it was about two years before we received our
first check from electric love after its release
but as assuming you do it correctly then you can
certainly make money back doing that and it's what
I really respect about the duploss brothers
they figured out their business model and it
works for them and and I I've always had a lot of
respect for them they create their own material
they have their pipeline they put it through
they produce other other people's movies and
it's profitable and they're able to do it again
and again and again what is that budget range
that you think is the profitable budget range I
would say it's hard it's hard to give like exact
numbers if I had to break it down i'd probably say
try to keep it below a hundred thousand dollars
especially if it's not a horror movie
I think if you make a horror film there's there's
going to be a lot more distributors nowadays
that are willing to distribute something like
that because like we were talking about before
it can be distributed to just about any country
non-english speaking country and still translate
people will still enjoy it whereas a romantic
comedy about online dating in los angeles
won't necessarily translate to someone in japan
or some country that doesn't speak english as much
so yeah and you said your budget for electric love
was around a hundred thousand it was it was about
a hundred thousand dollars and then hulu we got
it we got 50k from hulu which was half the budget
and again I I like sharing the numbers mainly
just to to help filmmakers sort of get an idea
as to what they can do with these these with
films in this sort of budget range because
sorry do you mind if I ask how you raised that
budget sure so a lot of it was self-financed
I put up a little basically just savings from
like the past since 15 north for the past five
six years and it's not something I would recommend
everyone do I did it and it's slowly working out
but I was able to finance a lot myself and another
huge part of it and this is like the second half
is Victoria actually was able to lock a lot
of brand collaborations so she comes from a
background of instagram and doing sponsorships
and brand collabs and we were able to get a lot
of our wardrobe paid for free meals even money
given to us we had friends come in and just
kick in a little bit so it was very much sort
of like a crowdsourced kind of kind of thing
and honestly if I didn't have savings five years
worth of savings to put into it I still would have
made it we just would have done things a little
bit differently so it's definitely possible
and with these brand collaborations is there a
site you would go to to find brands or you were
just cold calling what might fit with the
movie or emailing we were pretty much just
cold emailing companies that had products
or services that we could somehow
include in the film without it being too obvious
I see so you're finding things that would fit with
the film and making a list and then reaching out
and finding who their brand sort of manager is
exactly and and Victoria is is so good at that
she really just excels in in that in marketing
and producing and everything in that department
was your pitch a long pitch or was it more to the
point to these brands it's pretty to the point
I think at a certain point too even when
it came to post we even had like a little
loose trailer cut together that we could send
over and say here hey here's what the movie
looks like and here's what it is and we even got
some brand deals after the fact when it came time
to putting together a premiere so yeah just be
direct don't be honest about what you're doing
tell them where where the movie might go and who's
in it that kind of stuff matters in that regard
and hope for the best I think if you send out
200 emails two companies might respond with a yes
with the brand email would you talk up sort of
like what you could do for them more so than
hey this is who we are I see a lot of
pitches and sometimes it's more about
this is who I am and this is and that's great
and I understand people are proud of their work
but sometimes it falls short in what they can
do for the person they're asking something from
i I actually would love to bring up one
of victoria's emails so I could just
read exactly how she wrote it
but I think she would sort of
focus on how this is going to benefit
their company while simultaneously saying
and and not in these exact words but we know
what we're doing and this movie is going to
have eyeballs on it so it's kind of like
we're professionals and this can benefit you
right and just last question about it
would you try would you email them a
second time if you heard no or or did
I'm sorry if you didn't hear anything
traditionally not I mean I I think we just
emailed so many companies at a certain point
that it was even hard to keep track of again I
don't know if that is like the best method but
I see no harm in it and if a no is a no it
doesn't it doesn't bother us we've had plenty
of rejection working in entertainment anyway
so if a company is like not for us no big deal
and if they don't answer then there's there's
plenty of other brands that we could reach out to
where was the premiere at the was it the I think
it was the aria fine arts theater on wilshire nice
yeah what do about filmmaking that you wish
you knew before and again I realized that's
that's like a typical job interview question
but there's a lot of weight to it and sure I
mean I think the really the biggest thing that I
have learned is just the secrets of distribution
the actual filmmaking part you you just you
just need to make mistakes in order to grow
so with the actual creativity and putting it
together and not planning and seeing how that
turns out and then doing a little more planning
and seeing how that turns out it's all it really
is all part of the process and it's it's something
that everyone I think needs to go through
even if they try not to they're
going to make mistakes it's necessary
to make the best movie the only like cold hard
facts that you can actually learn is pretty much
now that I made the movie how do I get it
out there and that's also always evolving and
changing so the the means of distribution seven
years ago is completely different than what it is
now so you have to stay on top of that but sort
of just understanding what your film's value is
and what is possible is the the biggest thing
that I've learned over the past few years
how do what the value is I guess what I mean by
value is sort of having the confidence to to know
that there is an audience for your film if you if
you put in this some if you put in a year's worth
of time and effort into making a movie there
is going to be an audience for it somewhere
there's there's a lot of people in this world and
and a lot of people have tvs and computers and
nowadays that's all you need to share content
and even if you can't get distribution
you can self-distribute now
like I wasn't able to do that
10 years ago and if I did then I just didn't know
about it now it's so much more user friendly and
you can get your movie on amazon prime like
that with with their amazon video direct service
so it really it's it's inspiring and
it gives me hope knowing that the
success of your film relies entirely on the work
that you put into it can you share with us the
process of getting your movie on amazon prime yeah
so it's a service called amazon a video direct
and I did I set this up about a year and a
half ago for our first movie and you really
just follow the instructions you upload your file
you upload your subtitles and after it's approved
you literally just link it to your bank account
and you have all the analytics and everything and
it's on you to market and promote your movie and
you can choose whether or not you want to put it
on prime so prime users can stream it for free or
you can set it to just for rental and purchase but
I think vimeo also offers a service where
you can do that so if you're interested
in self-distribution vimeo and amazon I think
are the best platforms to do that on right now
and what type of video file is it oh
I don't remember exactly what kind of
video file they require probably like an mp4
or h.264 4k file ideally I think you can put
anything any any format you want I believe
it doesn't necessarily have to be 4k and I'm
not like a master at the self distribution I've
only done it once so don't quote me on this but
but it's pretty simple and and amazon definitely
has instructions on how to do it properly
with the text of the the subtitles is it a text
file or how are you I upload it I think so I
think it is a text file I'm not I'm not sure I
think I remember actually going using youtube
I uploaded the movie to youtube it youtube has
an algorithm that automatically scans every word
and then I copied all of that text from the
youtube platform and then put that into the amazon
platform and then I just had to sort of edit some
of like the spacing and alignment just to match
but there there are ways to figure it out and
google has been very good to me in helping me
through that process so yeah but but yeah I think
it was like about a year and a half since I went
through that and I think I did the entire I set
up the entire self-distribution thing in about
a day or two really the hardest part was just
really just waiting for it to upload and then
get approved by by amazon and and there's also
a good chance that the entire means of uploading
has changed since then I've been getting emails
about changes to their service and layout and I
don't really check it that often I kind of figured
50 north is certainly a movie that I made a long
time ago I don't intend on searching for a whole
new distribution deal or anything so I figured i'd
just put it up on amazon and let it live there how
do you think teaching others on youtube has helped
you to become a better filmmaker I think it's sort
of forced me to come up with the most efficient
method of doing certain things that I can then
just apply to my own filmmaking and do it that
much faster whereas ordinarily i'd have to think
about how am I going to do this effect or I need
to experiment and premiere after effects trying to
figure out a certain effects that I'm trying to do
doing these tutorials I research the
hell out of a certain topic and then
I just streamline it so that I can say it as
succinctly and easy to understand as possible
so on some level it's also helped with
communication is I think if you can
show other people how to do something it helps
you do it even better and how has either receiving
reaction videos or getting comments shaped your
idea of audience feedback if it has I'm sure
it's it's happened more subconsciously I I try to
read as many comments as I can I'm sure a lot of
people are like don't read the comments that's
a bad idea but I like reading them even even if
they're not great I I'm i'm pretty honest with
myself and I have a feeling about the type of
content I'm putting out and where it stands and
with everything else and I see tr some truth in
some of the mean comments sometimes I'm like
they're just me and that's ridiculous and I
love the support and I love reading all the the
positivity and and most most of the comments are
are good like there's there's not too many people
that are just [ __ ] all over everything and
uh hating what we do and if if they are then it's
just it's not for them and that's okay yeah I love
it when people share about their process or their
life and you're reading about someone overseas and
what they do and to me that those are my favorite
comments just to hear other people's process and
absolutely I just released our first making of
video on our channel just yesterday actually
I mean I'm hugely inspired by david f sandberg
and I love that he does that on his channel
so I'm thinking well I love that he does that
I should do that for people that are watching
our short films why would I deprive them if for
anyone that wants to see it here it is so I put
that together and it's it's it's cool are you
excited to release your third feature film Val
I am it's it's going to be a lot different than
the past assuming the world is still closed down
we were planning on having a big premiere we had
to cancel our wrap party because of everything
but that that aside the actual making of it
was an absolute blast it was one of the best
experiences I've ever had making a movie it's a
horror fantasy kind of in the vein of beetlejuice
and yeah we plan on reaching out to some of the
same distributors that we've worked with in the
past and sort of sending out the trailer
and seeing what happens seeing where we can
land a home for it but I'm super excited it's it's
a different type of movie than than the other two
what has it taught you about storytelling this is
the first movie that a lot of people that know me
and worked on this movie have said
this is an actual movie and I think
what they meant by that is storytelling
storytelling-wise and character-wise
everything was just it was it was just
more it had a much bigger punch all the
the protagonists were so much more clearly defined
and the antagonist was clear defined dimensional
the set pieces and the production design we spent
so much more time actually looking for the right
locations and props and everything so I think
what this movie taught me was to really just
it's the endless journey of paying attention
to as many little details as you possibly can
to make the best movie and I think that that comes
with time because there are plenty of times in
my other first two films where I'm like oh no
this is good enough like the production design
it is what it is this is what it looks like
I'm happy with it now I don't really have that
mindset anymore I definitely spend a lot more time
focusing on everything and it's wonderful having
a partner Victoria with me by my side helping
and doing doing a lot of the heavy lifting and
and shaping characters writing a good portion
of like female perspectives for example
which I'm i'm oftentimes not too good at so yeah
I definitely learned a lot on this movie and and I
hope I hope the release is a successful one what's
it about it is about it's hard to say what this is
about without actually giving away the ending
but it's sort of a supernatural thriller horror
comedy very much like beetlejuice about a criminal
who's on the run and he gets into an altercation
with a police officer at the very beginning and
he escapes and he breaks into a woman's home
and holds her hostage and as the movie goes on you
realize that his reality starts to sort of shift
and change and things aren't really as they seem
and what inspired that we were originally planning
on making a movie a different movie that we wrote
last summer and financing was actually we lost the
the budget for that movie the financier actually
pulled out so I turned to Victoria and I was like
I want to just make a movie I don't I just want
to make something that we don't really rely on
anyone else let's come up with an idea that takes
place in pretty much one location with two actors
primarily and just do the best we can and she
liked the idea after a couple days of thinking
about it I turned to Victoria and I was like what
about a movie about this and she was like there's
some potential there and then she offered a really
cool idea which added a ton to the story we wrote
it together in about four months and I think
we're in production went into production about
two months after that so you're lucky you did
it before the pandemic we are so lucky honestly
the only reason I'm sane right now is because we
were able to shoot this movie beginning of march
and we rapped probably about three days before
everything shut down on set we were joking
about the the state of the world in like a now
very unfunny way but it was sort of someone would
cough and we'd be like oh you have the corona
and it was sort of a loose joke on set now
looking back it's like no it's a real thing
but we are all so thankful that we got to
work one last time for a while and get
this done before everything closed down
so it was just perfect timing and and I think I
don't think it's it's a bad thing for the film I
think especially distribution companies platforms
are because of such uncertain times it's probably
going to it might even help I think distribution
companies are looking for more material now
so so it might not be that bad for for the film
do you have any adr or retakes that you need to
do for there's some second unit stuff that we
might have to do there is one little piece that
we still have to shoot but everything that
we need to do from here on out can be done
pretty safely or even just hired out to be done
at on someone else's time and just by themselves
sure they can mail you the audio file exactly
yeah do something yeah yeah can you share what
it was like for the two months before production
so you finished the script and then you said you
had around two months before you it was about two
months since we finished yeah and of course we're
sort of trying our hardest to just tighten up
the bolts of the script during that two months
pre-production phase but that was pretty much
just meeting with dps directors of photography and
meeting with actors making offers to actors that
we wanted to be in the film locking our production
insurance which is one of the first things you do
getting your llc in line so that you can do all
of that just pretty pretty standard pre-production
stuff and then we went scouting for locations and
the location for this movie was very important and
we actually ended up finding the perfect location
in ojai and we met with the owner of this property
and it was just a beautiful stunning house and we
worked something out with her ended up shooting
the entire thing there and yeah to to raise the
the financing for the movie we had a sedan spark
campaign and then we also had some some investors
come on board that were fans from electric love
so they saw what we could do with the previous
film and they invested some money into this one I
took the the little money that we had made at that
point of electric love and put that into this
one so it's literally just the the circle and
we were able to come up with the budget and yeah
shot over I believe the entire shoot was 15 days
so it was tight did the crew and cast stay at the
house in ohio or that was the fun part everybody
actually stayed in the same house together it was
basically just a giant party for for 15 days in
this house in ohio and yeah it was just a lot
of fun a lot of great food and good times and
yeah do you set up these llc's yourself Victoria
sort of spearheads the the setting up of llc
she does a lot of the pre-production work that's
her favorite part it's my least favorite part um
but yeah it's there's a couple different ways
to do it I think for Val we did it on legalzoom
and then for electric love we actually went to
a building downtown and and filled out all the
paperwork in person but yeah there's there's
several different ways to set up an llc and
yeah what's the significance
of guacamole I love guacamole
what's your best recipe sprinkling a
little bit of the pomegranate seeds
on top of the of course avocado cilantro red onion
a little bit of lime although I'm not I could
do with or without the lime but the pomegranate
seeds it's a nice touch it's a real nice touch.
What do you like about this video?